[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing a theory
centered around SRA Snape and his
ability to fly we're also going to be
challenging the conventional notion that
Voldemort was the one to teach him but
right off the bat I need to make
something clear here when I say fly I do
not mean with a broom I'm referencing
snap's ability to travel through the air
without the use of the traditional
flying device a rare and exceptional
ability limited to a very select few in
the Harry Potter series in the Harry
Potter films we see the Death Eaters fly
on numerous occasions the first time
being in the Order of the Phoenix we see
them flying again later on in the half
Bud Prince while attacking various
communities
and because we saw them fly right in
front of our eyes it has led many fans
to believe that any run-of-the-mill
Death Eater can in fact fly however this
is certainly not the case the books at
no point depict the Death Eaters flying
only apparating therefore the simple
answer to this conundrum is it
filmmakers in the name of producing
interesting visual effects simply made
Apparition or teleportation look like
flying but just because the Death Eaters
couldn't fly it certainly doesn't mean
that no one could in fact there are two
wizards that come to mind when I think
of flying Lord Voldemort and Severus
Snape and it just so happens that both
of these Wizards possess the ability
known as unsupported flight and then
Harry saw him Voldemort was flying like
smoke on the Wind without broomstick or
thestral to hold him his snake-like face
gleaming out of the blackness his white
fingers raising his wand again JK
Rowling is reported to have stated that
all wizards have the power of flight
innately but that the vast vast majority
need a broom to achieve it in
Voldemort's case he was so focused and
Powerful that he was able to channel the
power to fly UNS supported harnessing
the energy through himself rather than
the broom this rare achievement is
indicative of a truly powerful witch or
wizard
we also see SRA Snape aka the only other
known flying wizard fly away from
Hogwarts in the Deathly Hallows he
jumped said Professor mcgonagal you mean
he's dead Harry sprinted to the window
no he's not dead said mcgonagle he seems
to have learned a few tricks from his
master in the books mcgonagle speculates
that Snape has developed his ability to
fly through his proximity to
Voldemort Voldemort was at one St stage
widely thought to be the only known
wizard to possess the ability to fly
therefore this was a reasonable
assertion by mcgonagal if Voldemort is
the only known flyer and suddenly Snape
can fly it stands to reason that
Voldemort would have been the one to
teach him however here's where the
theory starts to creep in while
conventional wisdom would suggest that
vort taught Snape to fly I think it's
actually the opposite while both Wizards
have a hisory history of continually
challenging The Wizarding status quo
inventing spells and experimenting with
all sorts of new magic flying seems much
more like something that Snape would
have pursued Voldemort was far too
preoccupied with extending his life and
his exploration of spells on the darker
side of the spectrum another strong
argument against Voldemort being the one
to teach Snape is that Voldemort much
like with his HW cers would never share
magic that would make him exceptional if
he and he alone had developed the
ability to fly there's no chance he
would share it with his followers even
if it gave him a Competitive Edge
Voldemort after all was arrogant and
wildly
overconfident but this does leave one
big question on the table if Voldemort
didn't teach Snape to fly then who did
enter Lily Evans laughing Lily swung
higher than her sister she quivered with
excitement about what she was going to
do Lily don't do it shrieked petunia but
her words came too late Lily had already
let go of the swing and was soaring
higher and higher into the air but the
girl had let go of the swing at the very
height of its Ark and flown into the air
quite literally flown launched herself
Skyward with a great shout of laughter
and instead of crumpling on the
playground asphalt she soared like a
trapeze artist through the air staying
up far too long Landing far too lightly
Lily had always loved doing this the
feel of soaring through the air was one
of her favorite things mommy told you
not to but Junia stopped her swing by
dragging the heels of her sandals on the
ground making a crunching grinding sound
then leapt up hands on hips mommy said
you weren't allowed Lily but I'm fine
said Lily still giggling tuny look at
this watch what I can do the text above
suggests that Lily Evans may have been
the first witch in the wisting world to
inadvertently dip her feet in the realm
of flight and who did Snape spend a
considerable amount of time with in his
youth why Lily Evans of course born on
January 9th 1960 s Snape was raised in
the Muggle dwelling of Spinner's end a
Shabby suburb of cworth attempting to
escape the misery of his home life seus
would often spend his time wondering
about his neighborhood as this was an
area where the majority ity of
inhabitants are Muggles most of the
encounters seus had with his neighbors
were with people who neither descended
from magical families nor had magical
abilities of their own so it was likely
for this reason that Snape was so
excited when at the age of nine he
happened upon the Evans sisters Lily and
petunia and quickly became aware of
Lily's abilities to perform magic it is
said that seus almost immediately fell
for Lily and the sheer fact that she
could do a little magic probably had him
Spellbound and almost immediately after
meeting one another Snape began to
introduce Lily to a lot of Wizarding
World firsts because Lily had hailed
from a muggle family she didn't even
know that the Wizarding World existed
until Snape explained things to her and
all thanks to Snape Lily very quickly
became accustomed to All Things magical
priming her entry into the Wizarding
World but I'm of the impression that
these lessons
weren't entirely
one-sided sure Snape taught Lily a lot
about the Wizarding World but what if
Lily had some things to teach Snape as a
Young Man Snape was infatuated with Lily
and her discovery of a relatively
unknown and unexplored magical ability
like flight would have undoubtedly
fueled his affection for her even
further now I'm not implying that Lily
Evans A young witch with zero exposure
to The Wizarding World could fly like
Snape and Voldemort could in the later
books and I'm certainly not implying
that the above passage dictates that
however it is one of the only passages
in the books referencing flight in any
way shape or form it's also the earliest
example it's also well documented in the
books that some witches and wizards have
certain predispositions to certain
spells or abilities and it's entirely
possible that Lily's special talent was
flight or at least the very early stages
of it before attending Hogwarts Lily had
no connection to the Wizarding World
Beyond Snape so it stands to reason that
she would have shared her limited
knowledge with him during their time
together and she'd hardly be the only
witch or wizard in the story who kept a
unique bit of magic secret Voldemort had
his Haw Roes Snape had his book full of
spells and the Marauders had their
animus abilities flight could have been
Snape and Lily's little secret as to how
Voldemort ended up with the ability well
there are a few possibilities the first
being that Voldemort simply figured out
flying all by himself he was one of the
most powerful wizards of all time and
when he set his mind to something he can
often achieve it him developing the
ability to fly all on his own is not
outside the realm of possibility and the
second is that Voldemort saw Snape
flying and subsequently demanded that he
teach him the ability Snape had to
conceal many things from Voldemort over
the years and knowing the power of
Voldemort as a legilimens it's entirely
possible that he recognized he would
have to concede some secrets to the dark
lord during periods of close
proximity on a closing note I'd also
like to mention that according to
Rolling every witch or wizard has the
innate ability to fly it's just a matter
of becoming powerful focused enough to
channel it just like a young wizard
learns to fly on a broomstick which and
wizards will need to work hard if they
wish to graduate to unsupported flying
what do you guys think does the passage
referencing Lily floating through the
air lead to a dead end or does it bear
some weight what do you think of the
idea that flight in Harry Potter came
straight from Lily Evans let me know
down in the comment section below and
please do let me know if I've missed
something here also if you enjoy the
content please like the video and
subscribe to the channel until next time
remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to
live